yeah a new game and let's go c4 c6 ok
let's transpose back to the pan off and
see if this guy's has any knowledge I
mean I don't have much knowledge as wide
also but ok it's going for the knight c6
line let's see what happens he's going
eat six yeah this is the most solid way
to play transpose into this classical
ecig setup I'll despite go about that
rook c100 Bishop d3 I'd like to keep to
take in one move on c4 trying to find
them good to waiting moves
hoping that he takes I doesn't okay
but what is this among the see file here
I wonder if there's some way to to use
this this weakness
yeah b6 doesn't feel right to me take
some f six texts on d5 I should be 5c
txt five night XD five now takes d5
Bishop takes g5 probably leads nowhere
I'm not sure that this leads anywhere
but
yeah yeah but I thought 92 what do you
do now I'm double attacking this piece
ruki eight I thought wasn't good i thot
97 he he needed to go and now he just
loses i think what about c6 this should
lose her an exchange at least she moved
the night i get the look unless i'm
completely blind yet not unheard of i
think i just win the exchange now yep
here's the exchange but i thot 97 teen
years ago this is by the way not
completely completely clear meds it
should should be winning for white but
my light square cm my light squares a
bit a bit shaky okay not the don't
player to passively now so i'm trying to
attack d5
he grabs be too now I just play i'm
queen bee three and take it take it Oh
what your back rank buddy rook e8 is
made
yeah this was a lemon yeah it was very
bad anyway just just exchanged only I
could have continued Bishop d7 or
awesome move this is now just rupee
eight major next move I'm not an
examination mode why not so like this
yeah the quick good game here I thought
he just needed an Iraqi eight looks
normal but 92 wins I think he just needs
to go to e7 him then we when we continue
and not sure maybe h3 even to to get rid
of Bishop g4 the the thing is that this
structure be sixes a move that black
doesn't want to play it it weakens the
the light squares a lot and in general
this d5 pawn is a little bit weaker than
whites d4 pawn I can more easily put
pressure on this pawn but then I really
wonder this b6 move irritated me maybe
it is a book book anyway and all no one
else wat by Don I don't know it and I
can of course just play Bishop d3 and
lose this temple with the bishop like
this
getting a normal isolated Queen strong
position yeah okay thanks for watching
this